hey leute und willkommen bei einer neuen
mode review heute für den mord bzw von
dem motto spot dieser motto stand für
die 1.3 punkt 2000 hat durchweg sterben
und dieser mod fügt ziemlich viele
verschiedene neue bögen in eure
minecraft welt hinzu die alle spezielle
eigene features haben
ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz da gibt es
hier den rain forst bogen der wird mit
einem stock zwei steinen und drei
verkraftet dann gibt es den eisen bogen
übrigens sorry dass vor diesem hohen
bogen oder allgemein für items bei mir
dieses - scharfes s und f steht das
liegt an meinem sprachpaket das hab ich
noch nicht gab dated das werde ich aber
bald machen
da nimmt der drei eisenwaren und drei
fäden bei dem gold bogen genau das
gleiche nur mit gold
dann gibt es hier noch den kristall
bogen da gehören dazu noch diamanten
anstatt diesen beiden eisen wie beim
eisen bogen dann halt auch fahrten und
reisen dann gibt es den blazing bogen
den ich besonders cool findet dass er
gleich aber gleich dafür braucht ihr
netter steinbeck zwei goldbarren den
bogen und die lohan rote beziehungsweise
place rott dann gibt es den ende bogen
für ihr ein ende auge zwei ender perlen
den eisen bogen und noch zwei goldbarren
braucht und der letzte punkt ist der
legia bogen der wofür ihr einen barren
zwei eisen bögen und drei pferden
benötigt ich frag dich bestimmt was
bringen diese bögen ich sage euch erst
mal ganz kurz der normale bogen den
könnte ich mir auch mal eben ganz kurz
holen da ist übrigens im creative mode
findet ihr die unter dem alten kampf
dann könnt ihr euch die ich einfach raus
holen
der normale bogen der schießt der ganz
normal ein pfeil so ganz normal der doch
ein normalen speed und dann gibt es
diesen rain forst bogen der wird ein
bisschen anders gecastet und der ist
eigentlich genauso wie der normale bogen
nur der iss länger haltbar
das heißt wenn ich schieße oder so der
held deutlich länger allerdings ist die
schadens dingsbums nicht ganz so hoch
nur ein bisschen höher wie beim normalen
bogen dann gibt es hier den eisen bogen
der hat der ist schneller der es 0 2
schneller also zum vergleich der rain
force bogen hat eine schnelligkeit von 1
und desto kleiner diese zahl ist desto
schneller ist der bogen der hier zum
beispiel eine schnelligkeit von 08
damit hörte tier schon tiere mit einem
schlag bzw wenn ihr genau treffen mit
einem schlag kommt darauf an bei einem
krieg oder so und naja also deshalb
schneller und erhält sich auch 70
anwendungen länger also der brauch 550 x
könnte damit schießen bis der wirklich
ich sag mal kaputt ist ja dann ich muss
mal kurz auf dem zweiten bildschirm
dann gibt es noch den gold bogen den
habe ich euch wünschen gezeigt wie er
den crafted das ist der stärkste bogen
von allen ein schuss und die tiere und
alles mögliche was sie abknallen wollte
sofort tot
wo ja ich bin nicht so gut im ziel höher
so gut
die sterben halt direkt da hinten ist
eine kuh aber die werde ich willkommen
treffen und was damit ist der ist
doppelt so schnell wie dieser rain force
bogen also der hat eine geschwindigkeit
von 0 5 das heißt der ist viel viel
schneller aber das seht ihr auch schon
wenn ich das man so im vergleich mache
das sieht man definitiv also ich weiß
nicht was bei youtube sieht aber naja
aber wie alle gold sachen es ist
ziemlich schnell kaputt 68 mal könnt ihr
den nur verwenden dann ist er schon im
anus sag ich mal
na ja da gibt es den kristall bogen der
hat genau den gleichen speed wieder gold
bogen hat aber nicht so eine hohe
schaden macht nicht so viel schaden aber
der held 1016 dingens wie heißt es 1016
könnte damit schießen
natürlich fällt jetzt erstmal keinen
unterschied auf von wegen jahr mit gold
bogen sind die sofort und dem christ
album auch aber das werdet ihr
feststellen wenn ihr zum beispiel gegen
den ender drachen kämpft oder irgendwie
sowas da braucht ihr definitiv immer
mehr pfeile und da ist der goldproben
dann schon besser ich komme mal wieder
kurz unter bei der seite dann haben wir
den usa hier
das ist der moment dies sei wie dieser
gegen bogen der legia bogen moment jetzt
muss ich wieder auf dem zweiten
bildschirm das ist echt ätzend weil
diese beschreibung von dem hat es echt
extrem lang aber ich versuche ich das
mal so bestmöglichst vino geht
vorzustellen der regenbogen hat ein
speed von 0 6 und eine haltbarkeit von
550 aber moment da seht ihr schon der
kant zwei pfeile auf einmal schießen
das heißt es muss nicht unbedingt sein
dass beide auf den auf den gleichen mob
gehen auf den gleichen ob es kann auch
mal sein dass die zum beispiel hat
gesehen
zweiter teil auf einmal töten wir quasi
in double kill habt also der schießt ein
zweiter teil auf einmal das erinnert
mich ein bisschen an den typen von herr
der ringe der hatte auf seinen bogen
aber das ist ein anderes thema natürlich
euch mal den ender bogen vor und zwar
bei männern kommen wieder hoch
scorekarte schritt ich bitte das zu
entschuldigen
der inder bogen hat nur einen speed von
11 aber eine haltbarkeit von nur 200
aber schaut euch das man wenn ich einmal
damit schießt hat er gesehen also manche
werden jetzt sagen höre dass gar nichts
passiert das war einfach wenn man damit
einmal schießt hält die komplette
minecraft welt an alle mops kurz so ihr
seht das und dann schießen fünf pfeiler
auf einmal also quasi ihr fesselt diesen
diesem mob dann eigentlich mit dem pfeil
am boden sage ich mal und dann wird er
von fünf anderen pfeil noch
abgeschlossen ich kann mir da einfach
einen hin schießen und da mal hingucken
jetzt sind irgendwie noch da unten
geflogen aber das geht auch wenn ihr
halt einfach unter euch schießt dann
kommt er gleich auf fünf teile so habt
ihr gesehen also in so einem kleinen
radius also mein lieblingsteil der
blazing pro hat eine haltbarkeit von 576
576 mal schießen und hat eine eins pete
von 0.6 irgendwie bewegen sich bei mir
doch die bewegen sich und bei dem ist
einfach besonders die teile brennen
sofort also die mobs wenn ich jetzt
irgendwo man schwein finden würde wäre
das noch allerliebst oder waren hier
nicht klar wann kühe
ich weiß nicht ob das bei kühen auch
geht ich weiß bei schwein geht das dann
bekommt ihr verrottetes gebratenes
fleisch das ist ja auch der fall also
ihr seht ihr gebratenes fleisch sofort
im inventar auf jeden fall sehr geil was
ich mir bei diesem mord ehrlich gesagt
noch wünschen würde beziehungsweise was
ganz cool wäre ein wolle bogen dem ein
bisschen mit wolle crafted mit ihm wie
grüner und roter wolle uns alles
mögliche und dass man dann wenn man
schon bald zum fall zum beispiel scharf
abschießt dass man dann vier wolle
bekommt und halten der farbe wo der
bogen halt draus gemacht wurde ich glaub
ihr wisst was ich ungefähr meine ich
hoffe ich konnte euch den motten
bisschen näher bringen tut mir leid dass
ich jetzt immer auf dem zweiten
bildschirm gehen musste aber die
beschreibung echt extrem lang aber es
ist alles gute erklärt auf der website
die in der beschreibung steht also
downloaden
einfach hier braucht dafür den modeler
oder und ich würde erstmal sagt ich bin
raus vergesst nicht das video zu
bewerten
mit einem daumen hoch wenn ihr es gut
fand mit einem daumen runter wenn ihr es
schlecht findet und ich würde sagen wir
sehen uns dann in der nächsten
vorstellung von einem mord oder einem
texture pack oder ein sieht aber die
wird dann wahrscheinlich nach con 2.0
schon sein oder halten noch vorher ich
weiß nicht ob ich da noch was zwischen
kriege und dann wird das ganze neu
aufgebaut sein also meine lieben freunde
wissen ließ